[Musique]
jean lassalle a entamé aujourd'hui son
16e jour de grève de la faim le député
béarnais estime ne pas avoir obtenu les
garanties du maintien de l'entreprise
toya l'europe dans sa vallée d'aspe
aujourd'hui lors des questions au
gouvernement françois bayrou a demandé
lui aussi des engagements je vous
propose de l'écouter ainsi que la
réponse du ministre de l'économie
thierry breton
j'ai une question à vous poser
vous êtes chef du gouvernement français
qu avez-vous l'intention de faire que
pouvez-vous faire
et nous avec vous pour renverser cette
fatalité je ne suis pas insensible
personne ne peut être insensible au
combat d'un homme
qui peut mettre sa vie en danger pour
défendre ce qu'il croit être juste il me
semble que les engagements de
l'entreprise sont sérieux et que l'on ne
peut pas qualifier son programme
d'expansion de première étape vers une
délocalisation
je souhaite que l'ensemble des acteurs
du département monsieur le député puisse
accompagner le souhait partagé par tous
du développement de cette partie du
département aussi dans les jours qui
viennent je ferai mon possible pour que
le dialogue puisse se renouer et se
finaliser et que jean lassalle à qui je
souhaite redire toute mon estime et
toute l'amitié que nous lui portons
puisse interrompre son jeune fort des
engagements pris par les parties
[Musique]